be honest but not too honest because
that is
dangerous nowadays did you like me
feel a little bit of sharden freuder
or maybe you just smiled or chuckled to
yourself
when you heard that donald trump had
been permanently kicked off twitter
yep to quote everyone's favorite
prostitute
big mistake big huge big
mistake huge so on the face of it trump
was banned for the glorification
of violence but banning a sitting
president from twitter feels a little
bit like
the thin end of the wedge just because
loads of liberals
agree with it and love the fact that
it's happened
doesn't mean that it's right in fact it
risks us all sleepwalking into
1984. apparently twitter was compelled
to ban the orange one for his rabble
rousing
after michelle obama expressed her
disgust
at his monstrous behavior which suggests
that the trump ban
could have been colored with a touch of
political motivation banning a sitting
president
no matter what he says feels
problematic especially when all the tech
giants have just donated money
to joe biden's welcome back to the white
house party
but all that was okay because three days
ago
anyone too trumpy would have just said
well
that's all right i'll just go to parlour
instead
big mistake big again big mistake
huge huge you could have had these two
alternate echo chambers left versus
right
just as tragically blind to each other
as they are in real life
the self-righteous twitter arty versus
the
parlor capital raiders but now apple
and google play have banned parlour from
their platforms and as the final blow to
free speech
amazon has refused to host it which
means that freedom of expression
however unpleasant it may sometimes be
is now well and truly shut down